[Music]
internationally renowned chef Yotam Oleg
II has made a name for himself by
creating recipes influenced by his
Israeli heritage he's the owner of
several delis bearing his name and a
high-end restaurant no P in London his
award-winning cookbooks have sold more
than 3.7 million copies worldwide or
Alinghi is now out with his first
dessert cookbook called sweet
we welcome yo Tom eleni eleni is the
name of the restaurant thank you so much
this is such a beautiful tell us why you
wanted to do sweet do desserts well I
was trained as a pastry chef this was my
first job in the kitchen when I was
younger I worked in the pastry
Department in a fancy restaurant my job
was to whip up egg whites for meringue
so the pastry chef told me stand in the
corner whenever I got an order of my off
off souffle you whip up the egg whites
for me that was my first time I whipped
up egg whites and I've been doing it
ever since
yeah expert when it comes to whisking
the egg white yes I think I have I mean
we have in our shops in London we have
these mountains of meringues people who
come in they are kind of absorbed by
meringue because it is we do them really
big we do meringue big time so there's
raspberry meringue and cinnamon meringue
and chocolate meringue and they're all
over you as you know a lot of people
make sugar the enemy yeah
all right what do you say to those
people who say sugar is part of that
probably like anything you could abuse
it or you can use it and I think sugar
that comes from snack bars or savory
food in packages all the hidden sugars
what you don't want to consume but make
making a cake and baking it makes you
it's a it's a really lovely home ritual
and it would be a shame to lose this
whole but a bit of the culinary arts
just because we're a bit obsessed about
sugar at the moment it's good way
through sugar and they're bad ways you
agree you say cookies are happy making
you say cakes are a little bit magic and
you say tarts and pies or a sense of
occasion yeah I love how you
descriptively named all the different
categories but you believe or do you
believe that anybody can be a baker
absolutely but you think baking is
different than cooking any other type of
food yeah the instructions in my cooks
yeah instructions in the baking recipe
are very very clear you know you've got
the size of the pan you've got the
temperature you know how long you're
gonna bake it when you cook a fish it's
very easy to overcook it but with the
cakes normally a good recipe really
gives you the guidelines and in this
book we really tried Helen go my
co-author and myself to hold your hand
through the recipe and give you a good
result yeah some of the recipes seem
sort of elaborate you talk about rose
and sweet water you still think that
this is something that anybody in the
listening to us right now could cook
something out of this well we're talking
about this lemon sponge cake yes I am
gonna make this tonight I'm gonna make
this lemon sponge cake tonight you
promise nothing can you just get a tight
shot of this because I thought hello
gorgeous this is a thing of beauty what
you did on this chocolate flour it's got
almond meal and the chocolate ganache
that is a slightly more complex but
still very doable so we've got the whole
range in the book from very elaborate
desserts to really simple things that
anyone can do at home when they use your
name like a verb sometimes people talk
about after lengthy fiying a dish and I
think what they mean is making it
surprising so you eat something you go
oh I haven't had that calm that
combination before it needs to taste
great but it's nice to have a little
surprise so we have like chocolate tarts
in the book with with a crystallized
rosemary on top so rosemary is normally
associated with savory cooking but when
you add it to a chocolate tart it makes
it jump it makes it really taste very
special so we do these little things but
not all the recipes are like that once
in a while we add something a bit
different and it sounds like you've got
critics in your own house you know your
little kids four-year-old said I want
Helen to make it your partner that was
pretty funny
Helen like author she's a great Baker
and my little boys love her cake you say
well dad knows how to cook too guys very
nice
Yotam
you think he's so much sweet lady
Charlie beautiful